اسرائيل تتوعد من حدود لبنان بمحاسبه
مسؤوليه تفجير مجده
عمل لبناني الاصلي استجوب صدام حسين كشف
شيئين عني بثوان
تبرئه امريكي كان محكوما عليه بالسجن
لاربع مئه عام
هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقولها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
بعد الهجوم الذي استهدف مفترق مجد شمال
اسرائيل توعد وزير الدفاع يوقف بمحاسبه
المسؤولين عن هذا الهجوم فيما المحت مصادر
اسرائيليه الى احتمال ضلوع ميليشيا حزب
الله اللبناني فيه
خلال جوله على الحدود الاسرائيليه
اللبنانيه انا من نفذ الهجوم سيندم وسيتم
الرد في التوقيت المناسب وبالطريقه
الملائمه فيما تاتي تصريحات الوزير
الاسرائيلي بعدما اعلن الجيش ان قوات
الامن قتلت رجلا كان يحمل حزاما ناسفا
تسلل من لبنان الى اسرائيل وفجر عبوه
الناسفه ادت الى اصابه شخص بجروح خطيره
كشف عميل المخابرات الامريكيه اللبنانيه
الاصل جورج بيرو الذي استجوب الرئيس
العراقي الراحل صدام حسين لمده سبعه اشهر
كشف ان الاخير اكتشف عنه شيئين اثنين في
غضون اول 30 ثانيه فقط من لقائهما وفي
مقابله مع شبكه
انه حين اخبر صدام باسمه ساله على الفور
هل انت لبناني فاخبره بيرو ان والديه
لبنانيان مضيفا ان صدام قال بعدها له انت
مسيحي ليرد عليه بيرو اذا كانت لديه اي
مشكله في ذلك الا انه لم يبدي اي اعتراض
بل وقال له احب اللبنانيين
الى مصر هذه المره حيث سيطرت حاله من
الحزن على منصات التواصل الاجتماعي بعد
وفاه ام شابه بمرض السرطان في محافظه
المنوفيه تاركه وراءها وصيه مؤثره الراحله
صاحبه 39 عاما كانت كتبت على فيسبوك انها
تطلب من اصدقائها حضور جنازتها وان يدعو
لها ويقرا القران كما طلبت من مشيعي
جثمانها اي ظلوا معها لساعه او اثنتين بعد
دفنها ليكونوا ونسا لها فيما اثارت هذه
الكلمات تعاطفا واسعا على السوشيال ميديا
لما فيها من كلمات مؤثره
في اخبار عالم التكنولوجيا افادت وسالوا
اعلام البريطانيه ان حكومه المملكه
المتحده ستحضر تطبيق تيك توك عن كافه
الاجهزه الرسميه تقارير كشفت ان المركز
الوطني للامن السيبراني في المملكه
المتحده اجرى مراجعه ناصح بعدها بضروره
حظر التطبيق الصيني من الهواتف الحكوميه
مشيره الى ان وزيره مكتب مجلس الوزراء
اوليفر دودن سيعلن تفاصيل الحظر الجديد
خلال جلسه مرتقبه لمجلس العموم البريطاني
فيما تاتي هذه الخطوه في اعقاب التحركات
مماثله في الولايات المتحده وكندا وبلجيكا
بسبب مخاوف تتعلق بالاماني والخصوصيه
وفي خبرنا الاخير قضت محكمه امريكيه
بولايه فلوريدا ببراءه رجل كان يقضي حكما
بالسجن لاربع مئه عام بتهمه السطو المسلح
صحيفه الجاردن اوضحت في تقرير لها ان
تبرئه سيدني هومز اتت بعد ان قررت الولايه
اعاده التحقيق في حادث سطو مسلح وقع في
عام
1988 اتهم فيه الرجل حينها بسرقه سيارات
والتسبب بقتل عدد من الاشخاص فيما قضى
هولمز البالغ من العمر حاليا 57 عاما قضى
اكثر من 30 عاما خلف القضبان قبل ان يتم
اطلاقه سراحه مؤخرا نتيجه لاصراره على انه
بريء من التهم الموجهه اليه